me criei na moda no mundo da moda
comecei por aí goiano os desfiles e eu
me divertia muito com esses momentos e
ao mesmo tempo eu achava tudo muito
exagerado acho que não precisava ser
daquele jeito mas enfim eu me diverti
foi super marcante para mim eu trabalhei
revistas femininas em sites feminino e
eu tinha que escrever a respeito de
tendência de moda eu tinha que digitar
regra
isso pra mim era muito chato eu fazia
mas o que me movia mesmo que me
encantava era falar de moda como arte da
história da moda da moda com identidade
como comportamento era isso que eu
gostava de fazer
além de viajar também para ver os
desfiles fora uma vez por ano ea partir
de nova iorque ser o máximo
eu achei que estava no meu caminho só
que aí veio o planeta sustentável eu
recebi um convite pra criar e implantar
e dirige o site esse projeto grande da
editora abril foi em 2007 que foi um
desafio assim esse desafio achei o
máximo
morri de medo e foi a melhor coisa que
eu fiz porque antes eu sentia falta de
alguma coisa eu estava fazendo bem o
trabalho que fazia com a moda mas estava
faltando alguma coisa e quando veio esse
projeto do planeta sustentável de
começar do começo mas a maior parte das
pessoas que estava envolvida não
entendia muito disso então a gente tinha
que compreender tudo isso junto
eu fiz uma conexão comigo eu fiz uma
conexão com as pessoas e com o tema que
até então não tinha acontecido e por
tudo que a gente fez ali por tudo que a
gente desenvolveu é a maneira como a
gente pensou rapidamente àquele trabalho
virou uma causa pra mim e assim que eu
fazia realmente compaixão eu tinha uma
vontade enorme de de trabalhar com isso
de gee nos eventos de ir para a redação
de discutir essas pautas
então realmente me pegou muito muito
fundo algumas coisas ficaram muito forte
que na verdade você precisa seduzir
quando se fala de sistemas comunicação
que faz a diferença é aquela que seduz
com uma nova perspectiva de vida ea
gente queria que as pessoas tivessem
entendimento é outra coisa é a questão
da
ser mais positivo quando você dá a
notícia claro que você não vai ser um
alienado e não falar do que está
acontecendo
roberto smeraldi mostrou a situação como
tá exatamente muita gente aqui falou
mas quando você fala dessa dessas
notícias ruins
é bacana quando você propõe alguma coisa
né de que maneira aquela pessoa pode
participar para fazer uma transformação
em relação a esse tema e ea questão de
fato de ser mais positivo de ter
notícias positivas pra dar pra você
inspirar as pessoas porque também se
você fica ali só falam das notícias
ruins você derruba e realmente você não
consegue conquistar e outra coisa é o
bom humor
a gente chegou a lançar um gibi para
falar de mudanças climáticas que criança
quis ler adolescente que nem adulto que
se lê e também o que a gente acredita
muito nos jogos até o edgar controle e
também sobre um projeto dele que é
maravilhoso e eu também acredito nisso
na diversão para você compreender esses
temas também da sustentabilidade
aí é tava tudo muito bom e em junho a
equipe foi toda demitida
o planeta na verdade não acabou e
continua lá de um outro jeito e eu achei
que no começo assim quando recebi a
notícia que talvez fosse o caso de dar
uma paradinha de d
é um tempo mas no fim assim no dia
seguinte já estava com duas jornalistas
conversando a respeito
a gente criou um outro projecto e foi
muito interessante porque a conexão da
gente ali mudou
como eu não tinha mais uma corporação
por trás por trás a gente estava
querendo fazer alguma coisa
sozinhas é é foi muito rápido
foi muito estava muito afinado e
rapidamente também outros colaboradores
boa parte deles é os boqueiros e várias
outras pessoas que trabalhavam com a
gente no planeta eles aderiram ao
projeto e mais gente chegando toda
semana a gente recebe e meio de pessoas
interessadas em inscrever procomex um
planeta ou escrever um blog propondo
coisas enfim então tá muito rico em
pouquíssimo tempo ele virou uma rede
para falar desses assuntos o que é
extremamente inspirador e e o nosso
projeto na verdade a gente quer falar da
de uma maneira positiva e sistemas a
gente está dando as notícias que não são
tão legais o que a gente quer inspirar
as pessoas para a ação
e a gente está conseguindo fazer isso já
nesse pouco tempo eo interessante é que
até e instituições também estão apoiando
o nosso projeto a gente não não ficou
sozinho é todo mundo levou em conta tudo
que a gente fez lá que realmente foi
muito rico e até eu acho que a história
do planeta sustentável esses oito anos
lembro quando eu comecei não existe esse
entendimento que tem hoje então em oito
anos a gente viu essa é uma trajetória
assim uma mudança muito grande da
informação de quantas pessoas estão
envolvidas com esse tema de enfim então
é uma história bacana e do planeta e
acho que a gente agora vai dar
continuidade a ela de uma outra maneira
sempre tem alguma coisa positiva que vem
então quando eu mudei da moda para a
sustentabilidade eu tive um pouco de
receio mas eu me joguei nisso e foi
maravilhoso agora perdendo a todo o
apoio da corporação que a gente tinha
para falar desses assuntos e por um
projeto próprio é também tem um ganho
absurdo assim a gente tem ali à nossa
essência
a gente está colocando a coisa de uma
outra maneira em um caminho então vale
super a pena
outra coisa que eu acho que é super
importante ea gente já teria micro
engajamento nunca se sinta tão
pequenininho que é isso que eu vou fazer
aqui não vai fazer diferença sempre faz
diferença
toda ação que sustentável ela tem um uma
tela reverberam então de um de uma
pequena nação que você faz vai vir uma
outra você vai conhecer pessoas que vão
estar envolvidas e tem o mesmo
pensamento que você o que vão trazer uma
novidade nem sempre é possível avançar
se ele é aderindo alguma coisa pequena e
depois ela pode gerar maior
se você já faz essas coisas se você já
há nessa nessa linha
detalhe essa ideia que tem muita gente
está achando ainda que não dá pra
prossegue eo último uma última coisa que
eu queria falar a respeito da conexão eu
acho que é tudo isso que aconteceu
comigo nesse tempo me mostrou que eu que
a gente deve olhar o tempo inteiro para
as conexões que a gente está fazendo
porque nem todas são legais eu não vou
dizer que aquela conexão que eu fiz com
a moda lá atrás com todas as pessoas que
eu conheci todo o trabalho que
desenvolvi não é que não estava valendo
a pena mas estava faltando alguma coisa
né e depois parece que ficou tudo mais
completo fica tudo mais cheio mas as
idéias mais legal então olhar para essas
conexões que a gente faz todos os dias
que com a qualidade delas é como é que
eu sou comigo como é que eu sou com o
outro acho que outros participantes aqui
do ted onde falaram disso também então
também queria falar de gesso e aí eu vou
terminar com essa fala dessa imagem que
nem eu a conheci em 2007 quando eu
comecei a trabalhar no planeta
e ela tem sido usada para divulgar uma
filosofia africana que é o ubuntu que o
resumo dessa vez a filosofia é eu sou o
arquivo nós somos nem a minha humanidade
existe porque a nossa humanidade existe
então eu estou aqui porque nós estamos
conectados e acho que é que é justamente
isso assim tem a ver com o título e
também da minha apresentação as conexões
que realmente importa é isso que eu
queria falar
obrigada